looks like we got a problem Houston my
wheel fell off it didn't even realize it
till it fell off reason being the
bearings disintegrated because I drove
it in the pond a couple times last year
to rescue some stuff cars and trucks
well as I mentioned before water and
wheel bearings kills them so I've got
the axle shaft on the spindle all
cleaned off got the bearing hole cleaned
out on both sides and grease and broken
bearing bits out now I have to show you
how to get a wheel bearing off are the
pieces this is the same as you do it for
like for example the rear of a car or if
it's a rear-wheel drive car how to get
the wheel bearings out of the front
rotors luckily for me when you have a
tractor it has the option of lifting up
any wheel you want to you know so you
don't have to use a jack cool so first
thing you notice we're now looking at
the back side of the wheel the big
bearing has a notch in the hub on both
sides that's your removal notch I'll
show you how that works you get a steel
bar or a big bolt with a flat end on one
end and you flip your wheel or tire over
so that the bearing hub is facing
towards the ground now you use your big
hammer steel bar drop it down each notch
give a few taps on one side and a few
taps neither side and keep tapping back
and forth with your hammer until you
knock the bearing out save the old piece
of bearing you need it to reinstall the
new one so you hold your steel bar and
angle like that and start whacking if I
only took about eight wax and my bearing
piece is out oh there it is now put that
aside for reinstallation to put the new
one in there's your new part the new
piece we got to press in new bearing hub
and race and XL dust seal
so just make sure there's a bit of
grease around the surface and set that
in the hole with the widest portion
always facing out then you set the wheel
flat on the ground clean up this piece
of and you use this to reinstall
the bearing and you also put it in with
the widest peace and peace facing
outwards then you put a block of flats
teal or something on it and tap it in
with the hammer now I have a perfect
installation tool set that on there may
be that way works better and start
whacking have to tap it evenly get it
down square perfect got to love it now
at the same method on the other side use
your flattened n steel bar catch the
ridge of the other bearing and knock it
out packed a sucker with locks of grease
and with your hands pack that with lots
of grease 2 of course it's got a big
calves Ian Ayre to hold grease and
you're all set for installation the
inner part of the bearing is in the hole
now pre grease the rubber part of the
new seal and install it and tap it on
square 20 got the other part of the
bearing packed and ready for
installation
put wash your on and your big called a
castellated nut castellated part always
goes outwards then the first setting you
make it is a little bit tight then you
rotate the wheel a few times set it off
then I back the bearing off to make it
looser to the first Cotter key hole
lines up I put the car turkey in than
the end and that's how you set the wheel
bearing have the right amount of play
which is almost no play but you never
run it with a tight wheel bearing or
it'll get hot when you burn it out so
now trying to put the dust cap on and
we're all done